guys the end of the season you just so
well so much to be proud of
third place how are you feeling yeah I
mean I'm a little bit disappointed
because I I think I've been like really
we got to the point where I was like oh
we could win and I've been dreaming
about it so yeah I'm sad that I don't
get to be the partner who helps you win
no I'm worried at parting listen when
you open that door I already won so I'm
the happiest man right now this is the
this been the best season ever said you
should be proud of yourself you should
be proud of yourself you should be like
it was amazing my first freestyle what
just gonna bring that up tonight was
your first time ever doing a freestyle
you obviously won over fans you went
over the judges what did you make how
did you feel when that moment ended oh
my god well I think I think when it
started I think I just dropped the tear
I was like wow this is it
wait hold on what what no rehearsals I
was like oh my god and then when I saw
her I was like yep enjoy the moment what
are you gonna miss most about this
journey this experience honestly just
getting to spend time with this lovely
human who like it's just taught me so
much about how to view the world and I
had to do live and like you know focus
on the pulse of things so I have just
grown so much by being in your presence
and I will miss having the opportunity
yeah what are you gonna miss most about
this one Wow
so and when there's so many things I
think just Ivana's presence man like I I
wake up every day I'm like I just wanna
be next Ivana like she had energy and
like when she lost and when I make fun
of her I want to miss that a lot
well smoochie smoochie theme for you
this season was transformation and
changed how do you feel like you've
transformed as a person this season kind
of what I described it would be talking
about before the season started I was
quite a negative person I would tend to
believe the negative thoughts in my head
and just focus on them and let them
grill me and this like the
transformation has been that now I can
catch myself doing that and say no I
don't want to do that that's not gonna
help me learn that's not gonna help me
grow and yeah I just I don't walk around
feeling so apologetic anymore you giving
me this confidence that I have something
to share and offer and that's really yes
that's what the transformation a really
special night tonight Emma Watson
sending you a message I also know that
there were some other messages that were
taped for you that weren't shown tonight
JK Rowling tom felton what did it mean
to have the support of your old cast so
nice on a watch I actually saw it before
the show some of it yeah and every yeah
because it really made me be like all
Dave got my back day love me and I
really I kind of what I was walking into
this and being like I'm just gonna let
myself be fueled by love by that kind of
friendship that everyone is showing in
that that warmth and yeah she has
someone who I've looked up to since I
was a kid and then when I got to know
her like I always would see how she to
handle things and be inspired and amazed
by that so I have her send their love
and support team qivana was the best
thing ever when I saw that I was like
wait what what Emma what what and lastly
what do you guys make of Bobby and
Shauna's win tonight Bobby is such a
prick I mean I think like Bobby's been
telling us the whole season he's like
I'm not gonna win I'm not gonna get
through and he's just like you know he
doesn't take himself too seriously it
doesn't
Charlie perfect he really relates to
people and what he does like you know
I'm talking about it's for the people
I'm doing that he really does that on
set as well he go
he takes time during shows to say to us
that was amazing I loved it which most
people are so distracted and stressed
they just cannot think of anyone else so
he's a very generous lovely soul and
yeah it was obviously unexpected you
know but he deserves all the love and
attention he's getting yeah
[Music]